[Music]
[Music]
i'm nick pilipiu director of data
science at cape fear collective
and today i'd like to talk to you about
our racial equity dashboard
cape fear collective is a non-profit
based in wilmington north carolina
we're committed to using our expertise
in data science to support
front line organizations in southeastern
north carolina
in their fight against poverty racism
poor health and education outcomes and
socioeconomic disparities
though we are primarily in our shop we
also use
tableau arcgis python and sql in our
analytics ecosystem as we ingest
store analyze and socialize data
from a variety of public and partner
sources
our racial equity dashboard is built in
shiny and ggplot
the framework houses tabs as separate
modules for each category of data
stories
the landing page contains a brief
introduction to the dashboard itself
our email address and a tab navigation
bar
for the data story categories across the
top
each of these tabs follows the same
format
a brief introduction to the category
followed by two to five
visualizations and stories
let's walk through one of those stories
now
the definition box tells us that
pregnancy related mortality ratio
which is pregnancy related deaths per
100 000 live
births is often used as an indicator of
a nation's health
the expandable explanation box gives the
viewer additional context about how to
interpret the visualization
this plot shows the 30-year trend of the
pregnancy-related mortality ratio of the
u.s compared to select economic peers
though these five nations began the 90s
at the same level
the u.s has since deviated from the pack
nearly tripling its maternal mortality
the country is currently 56th in the
world
we often hear pregnancy-related
complications due to age
for white mothers this risk becomes
apparent around 35 years old
in black mothers the increase starts
much earlier
the resulting gap means black women aged
40 or older
have a pregnancy-related mortality ratio
almost four times that of their white
peers
educational attainment is another
indicator of disparity
a college education appears to correlate
with a lower pregnancy-related mortality
ratio for a white woman
but has little to no impact for a black
woman
looking specifically at north carolina
we were able to
identify a roadmap of interventions
based on high risk pregnancy factors
and have shared these with our community
partners for example
increased access to prenatal care and
pregnancy testing would have a
significant
impact on pregnancy-related mortality
ratio
over the next several months we'll be
aligning our community data platform
including insights from this racial
equity dashboard
with the state-wide healthy north
carolina 2030 initiative
this will allow us to set attainable
data-driven local goals
with a focus on equity and
accountability through shared
measurement
i invite you to explore the rest of the
dashboard and to visit our website to
learn more about the work we are doing
in the cape fear region
please also contact me if you're
interested in volunteer opportunities
contributing to our social impact
investment fund
or if you just want to chat about the
data thank you
you